every year 14 teams make it to the
playoffs around 50 of them never return
like for at least for the next year
six weeks into the 2021 season several
of last year's playoff teams took a trip
to regroup
the brutal events of that trip
are still under review
ah i missed a breeze
yikes y'all look rough what i don't look
good either i'm just excited for another
mid-season trip to a normal not creepy
american house
i feel like we used to have better
records
bro how are the vibes
what the [ __ ] is he talking about you
know that goofy good guy
sorry we can't mess with the playoff
house wait where'd they go i'm sure
everything is fine i have total
situational awareness i'm having trouble
getting reception eh
yeah same
come in
sorry canadian reflex
[Music]
it's two masculine calamari no it's not
me fam nah that's kind of it's very
recognizable hey i'm joe burrow and it
doesn't even bother me that i'm on the
bengals
i love you but just one question aren't
we all doomed for regression doom for
regression doom for regression doom
forward razor kick ow
well yeah washington was in the playoffs
last year i won't be long in the nfc's
we just sort of treat the playoffs like
a time chair enjoy the playoffs ah thank
you we won't
hot rod has gone cold they suck our
blankenship we need to get over to the
playoff lock cabin who wants more i
don't want some more i want some most
okay i think it's this key hey what's up
fam i'm everywhere oh god they must have
split coaches okay so the mistake most
slashers make is you got to make sure
that they're dead analytics prefers an
extra stab or two yeah sure whatever
what are you wearing bro get it i'm zach
sailor i thought we were all dressing up
for the halloween episode
i love the chase but i'm chase different
chase
oh sorry for screaming they got clay
pool i think my window is closed
but you could make a run but we forgot
to invest in defense and win in the
shootout don't touch me i said i'm out
coming for that playoff spot
hello your record is the same as the
bronco
[Music]
we are hearing reports that a dangerous
man has escaped from detroit what
happened here i know i can't believe
this either